voilà probablement le smartphone de
l'année de shiao me qu'on attend d'elle
il ya beaucoup de smartphones me
direz-vous qu'on attend le xiaomi 12 qui
effectivement le gros flagship shlomi 12
ultra chaud mais d'où ce procès pas à
quelle sauce on va être mangé chez
chaumet cette année mais ça c'est un
smartphone en tout cas un des
smartphones qui se vendra le plus choisi
un des smartphones l'un de la famille
des smartphones parce que ici je
présente aujourd'hui le chiot miller et
demi note 11 ont été officialisés pas
forcément france ne vont pas tarder à
arriver le chiot minott 11 juin 1911 est
ce le onze pros le onze pros 5g dizaine
compliqué l'histoire il aime avoir
beaucoup de références avec des petites
variantes à droite à gauche alors celle
là la variante qui est intéressant
intéressante surprenante intéressant que
c'est qu'ici c'est un smartphone 4g on a
un processeur qui supporte de la 4g
n'est pas de la 5g donc si vous n'avez
pas besoin de 5 g et que vous voulez un
smartphone 4g qui sera forcément moins
cher qu'un smartphone 5g rémy note 11
alors le radiothon je donne tout de
suite il coûte en version 4 64 199 euros
90 on est à moins de 200 euros plutôt
bien et en version 428 249 euros 90 est
ce que vous voulez un smartphone 4g est
ce que vous voulez un smartphone soit
j'ai dit oui tout de suite en
commentaire est ce que pour vous le fait
de ne pas avoir 5 g en 2022 c'est
rédhibitoire ou a contrario est ce que
vous vous en fichez d'avoir la 5g est-ce
que la 4g vous suffira marqué le monde
c'est super intéressant c'est vraiment
bien pouvoir voir quel smartphone va
être fait pour vous quel rémy note 11
parce qu'on aura plusieurs vagues fait
pour vous en tout cas tout de suite on
commence par le tout premier simple
basit le nom est comme ça xiaomi rémy
notre onze
sans plus attendre on ouvre on regarde
regarde et vous si vous le marque ici en
plein milieu powered by rainbow power et
demi note baishi au mythe bien que vous
ayez un petit logo mais ici c'est parce
qu'en faire et demie devient alors à
l'étranger un pas ici à l'international
une marque un peu à part je vous ai fait
une vidéo vous parlez de son leader pour
vous faire une vidéo pour vous parler de
shiao me versus samsung est ce que
xiaomi à la capacité de flinguer samsung
est de devenir leader numéro un il dans
cette vidéo j'explique un peu les gammes
et les souks gamme les sous-marques
parce qu'en fait c'est plus des sous mac
on a chaud micasa galschiot michaud
midouze et compagnie on a également
réuni qui est une entité qui devient pas
en tout cas à l'étranger poko qui est
une entité à part tout cas ici en france
tout de suite aujourd'hui tout est parti
des chiottes donc c'est pour ça que vous
voyez chez homère et demi mais c'est
peut-être pas qu'à tout le temps a ici
on a quoi fait voir on a une petite
coque de protection pour leurs tiroirs
de cartes sim à la reine deviens dingue
le smartphone est on a déjà les
premières steak lagarde et qui sont
affichés justice'' qualcomm snapdragon
680 ici on est gravé en 6 nanomètres ok
on voit qu'on a un écran amoled full hd
+ dot display c'est elle qui trouve pour
la caméra 90 hier double parade donc
haut-parleurs stéréo qu'on va venir
retrouver ici de la recharge rapide 30 3
watts avec une batterie de 5000 millions
terreur et on va qu'on a une caméra avec
quatre objectifs plutôt bien quatre à
l'arrière ayant la vente avant vos 5
objectif 50 méga pixels pour le
principal on va regarder s'ils sont
intéressants s'ils sont sexy et tout ça
alors regardez je prends le petit bidule
bon voilà c'est très drôle parce qu'on a
un dôme at beaucoup de doubles briand
60e smartphones et celui là il est
totalement maths alors ce que le fait
d'avoir ce dôme est là on se dit qu'on
prend comme le committee de traces de
doigts malgré tout peu de gras de sébum
je ressens rien qui va se déposer dessus
mais il ya un côté un peu moins premium
avec ce petit d'eau en plastique mat
comme ça alors après me direz-vous très
honnêtement de vous à moi un petit dos
comme ça qu'est-ce qu'il faut venir
faire il faut bien protéger est d'abord
il faut bien protéger avec une coque de
mon partenaire rideau schiste ça tombe
plutôt bien parce que sherin aussi
disons des coques pour les chiots mire
et demi note 11 donc regarder on vient
ici on vient regarder on vient dans la
boutique on vient dans plus de produits
parce qu'il ya tellement de produits il
y en a pour les samsung galaxy s 22 y en
a pour tout le monde et lorsque vous
allez sur yao ming qui est juste là vous
regardez et vous avez ici rewmi d'autres
11h30 note 11 pro et ça ça me plaît bien
alors pour l'instant sont pas tout de
suite disponibles ils vont arriver ils
vont arriver vous vous inscrivez à la
newsletter et vous serez informé dès
qu'ils arriveront et vont bientôt
arriver alors je tourne cette vidéo on
est le 11 février il ya ce qu'on appelle
un embargo je n'ai pas le droit de vous
en parler avant le 16 me semble-t-il
mais je prends un petit peu de temps
pour le tourner en avant vu que je lai
relativement en avant donc lorsque vous
arriverez je pense à ce moment là sur le
site de rhinau chine via le lien que je
vous mets juste en bas dans la
description et bien vous verrez tous les
produits sa sévère mais alors je vous
les montre un peu en avance chez un
chien omis vous avez beaucoup de choses
ici ce qui nous intéressait surtout et
bien ce sont les protections au dos les
solides suite qu'on peut venir
personnalisé et on va regarder ça et
puis également des protections d'écran
qui je pense arriveront et puis dans
tous les cas vous aurez des câbles des
grands câble pour revenir le recharger
et compagnie vous invite à aller jeter
un petit coup d'oeil et puis n'oubliez
pas qu'avec le code greu 22 vous avez 5
% de remise ça c'est vachement chouette
alors on vient le personnaliser et pour
moi c'est plus intéressant s'ils sont
toutes les collaborations alors on a dû
spider man on va avoir du snooper on va
avoir 6 star wars hyper chaud est en or
du disney classics on va avoir l'équipe
de france de rugby qui est situé juste
la dragon ball marvel jdo dispense
[ __ ] yes mon pote mick et de la taille
des titans harry potter monde à
laurianne dragon ball z la nasa league
of legends bref il y en a de tous les
côtés le psg taqman pop corn my hero
academia je vous laisse aller jeter un
petit coup d'oeil via le lien que je
vous ai mis en bas dans la description
et n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez venir
protéger votre smartphone dans les
meilleures conditions avec le code greu
22 5% de remise c'est très chouette pour
venir protéger votre smartphone et si
votre chiot mire et demi notre onze
d'autant plus qu'il est un dock est pas
fou ça le rendra encore plus beau donc
ça c'est vachement chouette et merci à
rhinau shield avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo on a ici un smartphone que je
trouve assez léger 179 g donc c'est vrai
qu'il y assez léger la prise en main est
plutôt bon on fait le tour très
rapidement il est plus long que large et
heureusement c'est un smartphone sinon
ça sera un tube ça serait dommage mais
c'est vrai qu'on a une très bonne prise
en main donc ça je vais apprécier je le
trouve plutôt sympa on va trouver
effectivement regarder sur le suisse une
petite prise jack donc ça c'est plutôt
bien de l'infrarouge pour utiliser comme
une télécommande bouton de volume
capteur d'empreintes digitales sur la
tranche vous posez votre doigt ça
dérouille très rapidement donc ça c'est
plutôt bien ici 12 le tiroir de carte
sim plus carte micro sd c'est uniquement
de la 4g et ça je vous le dis une fois
de plus vous allez retrouver un petit
haut parleur un micro pour laver votre
micro mais comparé adduction bruit est
située juste sur le dessus et de la
recharge ici en usb c'est plutôt sympa
alors à l'écran est vraiment bien on a
ici un écran amoled c'est du full hd
plus on est sur une diagonale 6 43
pouces avec un taux de rafraîchissement
de 90 ans qui est vachement bien il faut
le voir garder ses écrits si on tourne
sur me why 13 alors me why 13 vous
connaître une vidéo pour vous par
l'ennemi whiteread en quelques instants
5013 l'abri sur un android 11 on va
venir voir nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est au niveau de l'écran on peut
passer sur un tome sombre comme on est
sûr de la molette donc séduit au lait ça
veut donc dire qu'un pixel loire est un
pixel est un donc ça veut dire que tout
ce que vous avez noir et six sont des
pics à l'état donc ils vont pas venir
consommer de l'énergie donc ça c'est
bien on consommera moins on ira moins
taper au niveau de la batterie par
défaut vous êtes un taux d'actualisation
à 60 m si vous pouvez passer sur 1 90e
si vous le souhaitez à vous de voir si
vous jouez vous mettez là si vous vous
n'avez pas besoin vous jouez pas vous
mettez sur du 60 m à plein de petites
options niveau de la luminosité un petit
mot de sombres programmé le mode son
niveau de luminosité un mode lecture ok
le schéma de couleur également qu'on
peut venir voir ici on est en intense
saturé fois et moyens le standard est
très jaune quand même moi je trouve que
l'intense escales du mieux et qui
correspondra le mieux après on peut
venir réchauffer les gens - les couleurs
un poil plus chaud c'est plus autour du
viol inch pas très fan le froid fait mal
pour moi par défaut c'est quand même pas
mal assez bien fait donc je vais rester
sur ce qu'on va avoir ici en
configuration de base à l'avant je vais
avoir un corning gorilla glass 3 et puis
j'ai un pic de luminosité qui va jusqu'à
minit un pic mais il dit attention pas
forcément ce que vous allez avoir en
permanence ici chez eux mais nous
annonce une luminosité standard aux
alentours de 700 dit alors ils si vous
avez des hauts parleurs stéréo premier
haut parleurs kellal deuxième qui est là
c'est assez médiocre le haut parleur de
gauche est pas fou
droite non plus un peu plus de rondeur
c'est pas ici pour avoir la meilleure
expérience audio hd brancher un casque
vous voulez vraiment existé un film si
vous voulez profiter de la meilleure
expérience c'est pas dingue dingue
dingue comme ça hein faut quand même se
le dire il faut le savoir c'est quand
même bien d'avoir des hauts parleurs
stéréo bbc com vous avez du bluetooth
5.0 vous allez pouvoir venir très
facilement connecter des écouteurs son
fils why not ça peut être bien ou alors
sinon si vous avez et bien au filaires
comme vous avez une prise jack vous
débranchez un petit casque très
facilement donc ça aussi c'est une bonne
nouvelle côté performance qu'est ce
qu'on a on retrouve le snapdragon de
qualcomm s'est ainsi 180 milles 180
aggravé en scylla nos maîtres ici c'est
un processeur 4g et non 5 g c'est un
choix qui est assez bizarre peut-être
qu'on se dit que pour avoir un produit
qui est relativement bas on va rester
sur de la 4g versus de la 5g pour venir
attirer d'autres consommateurs bon
pourquoi pas qu'on peut venir jouer à
des petits jeux je vais vous montrer la
regarde et hop là on va se faire un
petit tour d'asphalt 9 alors je vous le
dis comme vous avez ici 4 gigas de ram
et bien que vous ayez est un dragon 680
il ya quelques petits moments où on va
saccadé pas forcément lors du jeune mais
lorsque vous naviguez il faut prendre un
petit peu son mal en patience ça dure
pas longtemps c'est les petits moments
mais on va manquer un poil du fluidité
version 6 gia drame serait vraiment la
bienvenue pour venir crucifier tout ça
bien que vous ayez de la lp dédié à 4x
et bien que vous avez 2 le fps 2.2 en
stockage pour la lecture et l'écriture
sinon pour revenir je vois des je voyais
comme un petit asphalte 9 je dois
reconnaître que ça marche quand même
dans l'ensemble plutôt bien on peut bien
faire tourner plein de jeux ici du claé
store une expérience est quand même
assez sympathique en termes de
performances en termes de puissance
c'est pas le smartphone le plus
performant c'est pas là où on fera les
trucs les plus dingues mais malgré tout
on peut quand même venir à faire pas mal
de petites choses donc ça c'est je dois
reconnaître plutôt cool donc si vous
cherchez un smartphone pour la vie de
tous les jours avec un peu de
performance eh bien il se peut que leur
ennemi note 11 puisse est fait pour nous
d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous en
pensez juste en bas dans les
commentaires bon nous on va arrêter
sortir de là parce que sinon je vais
encore explosé mon score et j'en ai
marre gagner je présente au niveau de la
batterie on a une grosse batterie de
5000 millions par an mais ça vous le
savez enfin vous devrez peut-être
commencer à le savoir parce qu'on en
parle quand même plutôt pas mal c'est
dans les smartphones d'entrée milieu de
gamme ce qui est ici le segment de ce
raid mis notre onze eh bien on retrouve
des grosses batteries pour une grosse
autonomie puisque on n'a pas ici les
processeurs les plus performants qui
vous apporter la meilleure autonomie ont
bien compensé par des très grosses
batteries de 5000 melior ou si c'est le
cas ils vous avez un l'homme de charge
de 33 watts qui est quelque part inclut
la d'envoyer ses marques et ici le noir
sur blanc on a de la 33 watts et de
l'usb a et vous venir recharger au dos
ici en usb c'est donc tout ça est très
très très standard à noter en tout cas
je sais qu'ici et bien tac tac tac non
vous n'en avez pas vous n'avez pas non
plus les petits écouteurs jusqu'à
présent tout cas c'est une obligation
française d'avoir des écouteurs à
l'intérieur de vos boîtes de smartphones
pour éviter l'exposition aux ondes de
vouziers tout le temps le téléphone à
l'oreille maintenant pour des questions
environnementales on ne met plus donc si
vous voulez et bien il faut soit
utiliser votre casque avec votre prise
jack que vous avez peut-être d'ailleurs
si vous en avez bien écoutez bien écouté
pas mal sinon vous pouvez bien connecter
un casque ici en bluetooth comme je le
disais on tourne et y aura 1 min 13
alors mes oreilles 13 on en parlera très
très très très prochainement il ya
quelques nouveautés sur millau à 13 par
rapport à me wade 12 est mis avec 12.5
ya notamment quelques nouveautés aussi
au niveau des fonds d'écran mais ça je
vous montrerai dans une prochaine vidéo
donc si vous n'êtes pas abonné
abonnez-vous qui sur le petit bouton
rouge et si vous êtes déjà abonné bien
actionner la cloche pour être notifiée
quand la prochaine vidéo arrivera comme
ça vous saurez tout comme ça vous verrez
un petit peu ce que ça raconte parce
qu'il ya quand même pas mal de petites
choses plutôt intéressante et assez
rigolote ici sur me why 13 alors que
maintenant le truc qui nous intéresse
vachement c'est toute la partie photo
vidéo parce qu'au sein des usages
extrêmement fort et ça les fabricants de
smartphones l'ont bien compris alors
comme à chaque fois ici on retrouve
beaucoup de capteurs mais en réalité
vous avez un seul et vrai capteurs qui
est intéressant c'est celui-là ça 150
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.8 sinon vous
en avez quatre autres mais c'est
vraiment histoire de ce marin vous avez
un grand ensemble alors attendez le
grand-angle je n'arrive même pas savoir
où il est je dirais que c'est celui là
là en haut à gauche ça neutre à
contre-tendance un ultra grand-angle
parlera donc ça c'est quand on pense à
celle ultra grand-angle avec le champ de
vision de 118 degrés ici on
un 8 mégapixels couvre f 2.2 puis vous
avez deux petites caméras ici si on
diago 1 pour la macro lot pour la
profondeur 2 mégapixels touvre f 2.4 on
va regarder ça dans quelques instants
mais je suis pas convaincu que ce soit
ou et puis on a à l'avant une caméra ici
de 13 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 qui
est là pour les selfs y est on va
également se le regarder alors on peut
bien faire de la photo mais j'ai
également de la vidéo pour autant est ce
que c'est vraiment un smartphone
utilisable pour faire de la vidéo je
suis pas convaincu pour venir filmer
jusqu'en 1080p à 30 images par seconde
donc on va se calmer parce qu'ici on va
pas avoir à l'agro stabilisation qui va
bien et compagnie donc on va quand même
y aller un petit peu un petit peu mollo
mollo la macro vous l'avez vous venez
l'enclencher ici alors on va se tester
sur le terrain mais une fois de plus su
pas très convaincu par ces mâles gros
comme ça ici la voyez bon voilà la
famille zarate tout ça c'est vraiment
pas terrible terrible mode portrait on
peut également venir pousser un mode à
50 méga pixels le mode nuit bon voilà
donc pas une vue logiciel ya toujours
quelques petits trucs en plus on se
regarde ce résultat effectivement dans
quelques instants sur toute la partie
photo vidéo on va pas y aller parce que
je ferai ça risque d'être pas terrible
terrible
j'étais faire des photos avec les chiots
miré minhotos dans leurs jouets ont
trôné sur un smartphone ici d'entrée
milieu de gamme voire à l'entrée du
milieu de gamme ce qui fait qu'on
s'attend pas à voir le photophone ce
photophone vous montre regarder si vous
êtes sur votre capteur principal vote 50
méga pixels c'est correct ça
fonctionnera on le voit le niveau de
l'action des hautes lumières qu'on va
voir ici place de la bastille bon cela
me semble pas trop mal on peut se
rapprocher en x 2 mais on commence à
avoir déjà du bruit on le voit pas ce
que c'est zoom numérique et c'est pas
ouf alors on peut aller beaucoup plus
loin et c'est très surprenant d'ailleurs
que nous ait permis d'aller aussi loin
sur mais on peut faire du x 4 c'est pas
beau on peut faire du foie si ce nom on
peut faire du 8 au lala et même du x 10
voilà donc on ne va pas où mais on reste
enfin on ne nomme pas ça c'est du très
grand temps je trouve forcément moins
bon mais c'est pas anormal on a vu le
prix du smartphone ça va me dire des
ceintures et ça sera moins bon la
gestion de la plage dynamique on n'y
sera pas donc bon voilà ces histoires 2
si vous voulez mais je ne vous le
recommande par capteur principal on fera
le taf attention route lumière malgré
tout ici et là j'étais un peu poussif
avec différentes expos c'est pas parfait
mais une fois de plus qui ont commencé
un peu moins de 200 euros on s'en
doutera le reste est pas ou ultra
grand-angle et hautes lumières il a du
mal très imprécis s'ébruiter c'est pas
terrible si vous vous allez bien vous
allez récupérer du bruit de la précision
sa sais pas où je trouve que même là
dans des zones un peu plus faible il
n'ya pas correction d'expo le ciel est
cramé il ya un côté très possible pour
récupérer la façade du bâtiment tout le
reste en bas et très sombre donc on s'en
doutera c'est pas un photophone là sur
l'ultra grand temps où il n'y a pas
beaucoup de lumière et bien il ya du
bruit c'est cramé c'est sombre enfin
bref voilà c'est un beau j'ai tenté de
venir ou non un peu plus histoire 2 mais
bon voilà on oublie caméra principale
avec un peu de lumière c'est là où on
obtiendra vraiment les meilleurs fausses
barbes passer de la photo il faut de la
lumière pour la photo et sinon j'aurais
tout fait à peu près les mêmes retour
pour pour le reste elle a regardé caméra
principale ou qui est ultra grand angle
voilà faut vraiment beaucoup de lumière
pour avoir eu trop grand angle et leur
est bon on peut mais faut-il je ne suis
pas convaincu pareil de l'autre côté
même reproche au niveau de la gestion de
lumière il est pas officines bon voilà
je montre à la caméra de cellfish n'est
pas les pattes d'arguin non plus parce
que l'on trouve beaucoup ça va chercher
au mit à côté très lisse et au niveau
des pots pour venir compenser ce que le
smartphone n'est pas capable de faire on
voit qu'à l'arrière plan c'est quand
même relativement bien cramé j'ai une
peau très lisse et qui malgré tout
laisse apparaître du bruit c'est pas
dingue alors il existe un mode nuit
faut-il y aller la réponse est non poser
votre smartphone sur un trépied mais
même ô combien et bien d'un pôle du
algorithmique on voit ci doit y
récupérer ce que d'un point de vue
optique on ne peut pas faire mais comme
on n'a pas non plus encore ce sera
extrêmement puissant fera pas de magie
mais c'est normal ça tout ça c'est
normal si vous voulez donc je dirais
qu'en terme de photos on peut faire des
choses correctes sur ce smartphone avec
votre capteur principe avec votre 50
méga pixels après c'est tout s'arrête là
de l'autre côté on est à un peu moins de
200 euros donc bon ça me paraît assez
logique
ici vous avez un indice de réparabilité
de 5,8 sur 10 ce qui est plutôt bien il
est certifié ip 53 vous avez du nfc
notamment pour le paiement dématérialisé
et vous avez ici 2 confie que vous avez
une conflit 4,64 qui est comme je
voulais dit à 199 euros 90 et une config
428 à 249 euros 90 d'ailleurs si ça
smartphone qui vous intéresse et bien je
vous mets un lien juste en bas dans la
description vous cliquez et vous pouvez
venir l'htc un smartphone que je trouve
assez sympa il est plutôt pas mal il
fera de chevaux sans en faire trop va
pas avoir la meilleure fluidité ici
c'est clair que nos va pas avoir la
meilleure expérience mais pour un
smartphone aux alentours des 200 euros
je trouve assez honnête maintenant y'a
vraiment la question à se poser c'est la
question de la 5g vous voulez aller dans
la salle g parce que ça se bastonne que
vous avez gardé au moins deux ans donc
ça veut dire que peut-être vous n'avez
pas de 5 g aujourd'hui que vous n'avez
pas l'abonnement saint jean et peut-être
que vous allez prendre un abonnement 5 g
plus tard eh bien c'était pas le
smartphone qu'il vous faut mais
peut-être que si vous ne voulez pas du
tout 2 5g vous n'avez pas le besoin vous
n'en voyez pas l'intérêt est bien il
peut être pas mal il pète vraiment pas
mal ça peut être le plus rapide sapec
plus d'un nom pour ajoie plein de petits
jours pourra faire quelques photos avec
le capteur principal pour va pouvoir
naviguer on va pouvoir aller sur le web
regarder des films des séries en
augmentant l'expérience en utilisant un
casque en est de la recharge qui est
rapide suffisamment rapide avec une
bonne autonomie voilà ici ce que nous
raconte ce smartphone ce chiot et me
rémi nothomb dont je trouve intéressant
à vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire comment vous
trouvez le rémi notons qu est ce que
vous voulez attendre côté studio parce
qu'on est heureux quand et arrivant j'ai
tellement de référence que je regarde
sans affiches c'est à dire leurs ennemis
note 11 ça ce que celui là on aura le 11
s on aura le onze pros on se protège et
à voir ce qu'ils vont arriver en france
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on en aura
d'autres donc on est est heureux
ultérieurement pour on se retrouve très
bientôt sur youtube pour parler de
shinobi mais également de plein d'autres
manon ça c'est plutôt cool vous embrasse
qu'on ait soin de vous et à très bientôt
car
[Musique]